in the silence of westminster hall
eight grandchildren made their way to
see their grandmother
prince william now stepping up as heir
leading his cousins his brother prince
harry so close behind him
their father decided that both should be
equals in wearing military uniforms
dressed in the blues and royals number
one uniform with medals marking the
queen's jubilees
the tapping marked their moment to turn
and stand vigil for their granny
difficult to watch at times
william harry and their cousin peter
phillips have already faced the public
gaze walking behind the coffin
but for zara princess beatrice and
princess usually heads down this would
have taken courage
prince edward's children 18 year old
louise and james only 14 had their
mother sophie and father watching for
moral support
for all of them their grandmother was
their example
summed up in a statement from beatrice
and usually released before the vigil in
which they said you were our matriarch
our guide our loving hand on our backs
leading us through this world you taught
us so much and we will cherish those
lessons and memories forever we're so
happy you're back with grandpa goodbye
dear granny it has been the honor of our
lives to have been your granddaughters
and we're so very proud of you
despite everything that's happened in
recent years this is a family showing
they are united in this moment and every
family member is welcome in this case
all of them wanting the focus to be on
their beloved granny and how much she
continues to mean to the thousands who
are queuing to pay their respects
jane holmwood and her family had come
from tumbridge wells the sight of the
royal grandchildren just heightening how
emotional they felt already
moving
incredible um touching
and what a privilege
and never
i think that we would walk in we came
through bang on the top of the steps
just as they walked out on the six
o'clock just
they're just very dignified and
that's what the royal family is all of
them have had to get used to living life
in the public eye
none of them fully prepared for 15
minutes like this
but all of them finding solace in being
together to publicly show their love and
respect for their granny
and their queen
rhiannon mills sky news
in central london